من العرض في الشوارع على حوائط المباني
الى شاشات كبيره في صلاه تسع المئات صنعت
السينما مرت بالكثير من المراحل لتصل لهذا
تطور اليوم فعرض الفيلم قديما لم يكن
بسهوله ضغطه الذره
[موسيقى]
من عندي
شغال في الشغلانه حبيتها شبطت فيها يعني
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فيلم بيخش والتروس وفحم بيولع كده عرفت
بعدها الاسم شربون
المفترض ان في مكانتين هنا ازيك هناك الله
يسلمك هم عاملين ايه ارقام
ستارت على الشباك بتاع العدسه بحيث اللي
هو ما بيلاقي اول علامه بيدور بيدور
المكنه على الفاضي اللي فيها الليزر ده
عقبال ما يقول السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
الحرب ال 30 قرش اشتريه النهارده ب 470
ليه معمول من ذهب
واحد للغيار واحد يقعد على الشربون ده
يفضل يقربه لحد ما الصوره تبقى ثابته
وواحد ياخذ الفصل اللي بينزل من المكنه
عشان يلفوا للحفله الثانيه اللي معلوماتنا
اللي الفيلم بيركب بالمقلوب يطلع بالعدل
عشان العدسه بتقلبه
الخامه اول ما نشا وصناعه الابيض واسود
والكلام ده فكانت ماده اسمها قابل
مشكله لو المكنه بس فيلم قطع فيها السينما
كلها بدات الصناعه تتطور شويه
بداوا يدخله الصوت يعني يتكلم كلمتين
وينزل في تتر كده زي افلام
بتشغل بالاسطوانه بس عشان الناس ما تبقاش
قاعده ممله وي وي وي وي
وبعد كده همم تطورت وعملوه
الشربون ده خالص اللي هو الفحم ده
من هنا اللي بيفهم الانسان